a bitter battle between exes and the new
girl in the middle of it all here's
Justin and Sofia Richie holding hands at
a mall in Tokyo
just days after Bieber whisks her off to
Japan on his private jet the new photos
are the most coupley we've seen them so
far but it's these more intimate shots
that are really causing controversy
justin's shares six selfies with sofia
and the believers make it clear that
they're not a fan of his new girl after
his followers post several scathing
messages about his 17 year old rumored
girlfriend bieber captured his final
selfie with this threatening message I'm
gonna make my Instagram private if you
guys don't stop the hey this is getting
out of hand if you guys are really fans
you wouldn't be so mean to people that I
like and then in come Selena the
normally kind star lays out a vicious
social media smackdown
commenting on Justin's photo if you
can't handle the hate that stop posting
pictures of your girlfriend lol it
should be special between you two only
don't be mad at your fans they love you
and supporting you before anyone ever
did she then proceeds to post a series
of shots that show just how much she
loves her fans adding the caption you
matter most
but that's when things get personal
Justin fires back suggesting that Selena
only used him to get famous it's funny
to see people that use me for attention
and still try to point the finger this
way and to that Selena says funny how
the ones that cheated multiple times are
pointing fingers at the ones that were
forgiving and supportive no wonder fans
are ad but Justin goes in for one final
jab I cheated oh I forgot about you and
Zayn
is awasum so did Selena cheat on Justin
with a former one Directioner back in
January Selena told InStyle UK that if
Zayn asked her on a date she would
happily say yes but that was after she
called it quits with Justin as for their
back-and-forth social media Slammy that
has been now deleted neither Justin or
Selena's camps have confirmed the
validity of their Instagram comments but
nevertheless the Internet has run wild
the hashtags
Selena and a Justin party is trending on
Twitter and one eagle-eyed fan even dug
up this meme of Sofia taking a picture
with Selena Gomez many years ago